our community is still in mourning this
evening after a horrific crash
left five local cyclists dead and three
others hurt
this happened thursday morning along the
u.s 95 right near boulder city
as the families of those lost continue
to grieve many are begging drivers to
be aware eight news now reporter madison
kimbrough has more from loved ones
tonight
and a look at our state's bicycle safety
laws
she joins us live in the newsroom with
the latest madison
yeah that's correct sasha so two
separate visuals were held today in
honor of the five las vegas cyclists
who lost their lives on thursday and one
major takeaway from each gathering
was the importance of safety out on our
roadways
put that phone down for that five minute
drive to wherever you're going
is it really that important to answer
that text
is it really that important to update
your facebook feed
this morning a vigil was held in front
of the ghost bike sculpture at las vegas
cyclery
family members and friends speaking out
about the loss they now have in their
hearts
but also stressing the importance of
safety while out on the roads
today is about our friends and families
and victims but moving forward it's
about awareness and safety
this afternoon a virtual vigil was held
at red rock where several of the
cyclists families came out
and spoke his real passion was cycling
donna troger wife of now deceased
cyclist tom trogger
urged the community to do better if you
leave here today with
anything please remember this
those cyclists that are out there riding
sharing the
[Music]
in the state of nevada by law when
passing a bike drivers must move into
the adjacent lane to the left
another option is to pass them with at
least three feet of space between your
car
and the cyclists drivers must also yield
to cyclists at intersections just like
they would for other vehicles and
pedestrians
so often do we head out in
five thousand pound
vehicles and reach for a snack or
look at our phones or not pay attention
and your simple mistake will end someone
else's life
now of the three people injured in the
crash nhp
says all are expected to survive one
cyclist hurt was airlifted to umc
in critical condition but has since been
stabilized
if you would like to contribute to their
gofundme page we have a link up on our
website
live in the newsroom madison kimbrough 8
news now